sleepwalkers just got your credit card
out there my flip that have you dealt
with any that [ __ ] do you have any like
concussion stuff made me funny dude I
did I was watching some Club I didn't
know that you knocked out Crow Chi and
watch that fight sometimes watch it from
start to finish
dude okay it's definitely gonna kick in
any day now so bro are you won't see me
while you can
you've got it punched full-on broke his
nose and you're like this brennan looks
attack crow congress but are you worried
about it oh yeah really for sure I mean
that's why that's how yeah but you know
how many concussions yet yeah I have no
idea I've had three minimum between
football and then just on record from my
knockouts and you and I won I got
concussed so I don't know dude I don't
know 10 I would say 15 to 20 Oh watch
out white kids here's the thing some
people some people get them you know
they have a ton of them in the it's a
certain gene okay where you're more
prone to suffer from gotcha
and I've had the test and I don't have
that you'll see you good I'm good yeah
we'll see I mean look it might not be
the best possible situation but you're
not gonna go mental it's like you know
some people they can do a psychedelic so
I think I think the red one uses his
brain so often I really think that also
has a factor keep it busy he does he
never you're always working out also you
see guys now I don't know when the way
you take care of yourself be the first
person to shoot up your own theater
surely the British cogs know who did it
it was Brandon himself
it was very strange with his family at
we celebrate matters so silly you know
his pop dude he's got a great sense
imagine he's on there going it's want on
Wednesday it's a very good Japanese
accent not a chance oh yes it's so great
we put up with certain accents I think I
never understood why are certain accents
racism at divide an accent for [ __ ]
chicken Wednesdays no what is it soul
food saturday my buddy no vodka by by
out cousin fleiger - he was saying that
he's like he's like imagine you just
came out like it's so full Saturday
y'all Jude don't not go over no not in
today's world not in today's know what
boring booking is I won't talk to the
grips no you talk to the [ __ ] hair
and makeup people yeah you never say
anything there's a therapist they won't
tell me you don't open their mouths you
know I don't give a [ __ ] how close you
are they will never spill the beans have
they might say something like this I
worked with him what's he like he's some
different complicated too different yeah
it's alright I remember I wanted to ask
I want to get inside the mind of the the
makeup ladies in haired people at ESPN
when I when I was there when I was
working yeah they were painfully hot now
singing of all the guys that come
through I mean all the bigwigs that come
through there and they do their makeup
you're talking about Ray Lewis Michael
Irvin Kobe Bryant the who's who is
always running through there and I'm
like God because these are alpha male oh
yeah I'm like there's no way a few of
these guys haven't just pull out their
old floppy gods I've been there I've
been well I dare say story about how one
of our one of our makeup people floppy
[ __ ] flopped because I'll never tell
you the story I'm in on MADtv we had a
hair person who was transgender and she
was basically full up well in fact she
went through the full up while we were
doctors a season yeah
and our second so was Jim showed up as
Jane yes and she was always always felt
like a woman inside she took her
sister's birth control pills when she
was 14 she was just a girl I never
thought of her as a man yeah that's cool
and Roy Jones jr. the great Roy Jones
jr. at the height of his career the man
yep he did a scene I think it was the
first year of MADtv he did a scene and
we did the makeup and he got right up in
her face and he goes man man if you was
a fighter man you look right through
people you look right through people man
you just the sexiest and he was right up
in her face I mean press and hard
because he thought she was a woman he
thought it was a woman man or woman and
I am saying to her I said you know I
said just be careful because you know if
he finds out that things are a little
bit different it could be you know he's
no joke and and because I knew he was I
was nobody else ago because I was like
that's Roy Jones jr. and she goes well
he's the one coming on to me I mean he
just like so hard and I was like I
that because you never know who are sexy
she looked really good I have a friend
who has a friend and she's uh she almost
say it is but the famous trans yeah like
really famous and she said she went
through her DMS yeah you should see
who's the nerd en oh I believe it I
believe it because I you should see who
it like you should see is it or day and
I went but I like yeah I go so there
Gayle you know there's not that they're
gay it's just like a lot of these
transgender have their specially the
ones that go from men to women they're
so feminine like they get so feminine so
and then I have a dick well the guys
like it I I could tell you a story about
being on my set of Mad TV and my the
woman who does hair her friend who was
full up and had huge tits who's did it
and a [ __ ] and hips and was sorry
gorgeous lot of yeah everything and this
was 1996 before technology will be a
little dicey I don't give up logics
later
I happen to know maybe I do and maybe I
don't that an actor who may have been or
may have not have been a guest star or
was on the show at one point or another
apparently they were getting changed and
he might have pulled his dick out and
gotten it sucked and a O'Brien oh all
Brides a straight man right yeah
you only got son no but I I was like I
was eyeing him up her up I on her up and
I'll be honest with you
your opportunity presented itself to me
I would have done it you know and I
would have done it for that I'm glad you
admitted this I just thought of it but
here's my thing
damnit it's when it's it's confession
Thursday it's confession Thursday
obvious only don't do it on Wednesday
that's right and you Kat and Cheney
getting chimed in on this if let's say
you had a friend yeah who was a guy yeah
and then that guy just had the does all
the hormones as the transition into
female and she's a bull
[ __ ] ten blonde ass if you think and
then you started dating her yeah does
that make you a gay man I don't think so
not really right I mean because some of
them are so feminine well okay so
explain to me how I'm gay if the person
used to be a man but now has huge tits a
crazy ass and a full mouth makeup no no
no that's not some of them all and you
have it but dude I was you can't
interrupt me I know it's like you can't
interrupt me with sucking and [ __ ]
because what happens is I go right you
just heard me off no I didn't say that's
strange
cuz I don't want to push anything out of
the way that'd be a distraction on both
of these that thing in my face
can't have a big old room I had a group
throw ice at me last night onstage at
the improv what group of Mexicans threw
ice at me wait you heard my Mexican bit
I think I'm mad at you oh yeah they did
yeah and they threw I see you yeah
thanks rice yep
what happened the security is in kick
him out like no I'm stayin stay them
stay and I just kind of clown them for a
little bit yeah cool like win him over
I want him over yeah but yeah yeah they
just need to know that you're not being
they know I mean everyone's having a
great time they know but it's like two
drunk ones so all they hear is the last
bit of it I know like this Trump tag
that I have so they hear that it's like
oh he's a Trump guy and then fill this
ice did you rob she just had a tits on
her and what you did the only reason you
know I can kick to ask yourself huge
tits yeah well that's the only reason I
said no that letter states just nine
City and she threw ice she threw ice
yeah big titties though yeah so I said
you could stay I think that's the right
move
oh me too I don't never throw never
never never kick you out double down but
it also gives me something to men talk
to them yeah yeah it was late it is late
it's fun I think yeah what are we gonna
do include him yeah yeah yeah
streams though right I had a woman I did
this Africa bit about how white
celebrities are da black babies and
and because you know it's like yeah yeah
and it's like a [ __ ] that it's like
an accessory right you know like the
more the famous area the more black
babies yeah and I do this whole thing
about but if they can never adopt they
can never adopt an American black baby
just drive right over to South Central
and get your mom foster care but no I've
to flout I'll do it to Africa you know
first class yeah this is bit and it
crushes it learns crushes layers and
there's just one woman like this hmm
and I go what's wrong white girl of
course well super it's always the super
woke the super woke are the white the
white privilige one zygote wallets and
ye I dug wells in Uganda and I got a
false alarm
oh did you dig wells am i are you
protecting the continent Africa huh
white girl are you standing up for the
Africans I'm making fun of people like
you you virtue signaling [ __ ] yo-yo
it's just humble you she's holding mr.
Joe just miserable and I just stopped
and I tried it debated everybody's
clapping for me I'm like you know you're
you you don't like black people more
than I do and you're not more
sympathetic to the cause just cuz you
dug wells [ __ ] began not walk out of
here
they just don't the problem with the
with super woke anybody on either
extreme I don't care if you're right
super level anything you're super it you
just lose your sense of humor cuz you're
you're into orthodoxy mmm they're not
open mind is at all misjudge oh they're
already made up their mind yeah the true
there's no winning yet they had the
truth